alors Tamara clairement c'est une
opération de représailles de la part de
la Russie et assurément pas la dernière
Poutine qui a confirmé en personne de
vive voix et ça c'était devant son
Conseil de sécurité de la Russie avait
lancé cette offensive vraiment tout
azimut c'est venu du ciel depuis la mer
Noire du sol comme attaque vraiment
terrifiant pour pour l'Ukraine et il
ajoute qu'il n'hésitera pas à continuer
au cas où l'Ukraine aux attaquer une
fois de plus la Russie donc oui il tient
l'Ukraine ses services secrets
responsables de l'explosion qui a
endommagé le pont de kerche et ce grand
pont et je crois qu'on a des images
c'est important parce que c'est central
c'est ce pont qui avait fait construire
en 2018 pour relier la Crimée et le
territoire russe donc ça c'est un grand
symbole pour Vladimir Poutine de sa
force et de du contrôle qu'il exerce sur
la Crimée depuis qu'il a annexé donc on
savait après cette explosion ce week-end
que la réponse de Vladimir Poutine
n'allait pas tarder c'est certainement
un prétexte pour escalader comme on le
voit aujourd'hui mais c'est pas le seul
Brigitte la Russie est en train de
perdre au front la mobilisation de
centaines de milliers d'hommes ça se
passe pas comme il veut c'est le chaos
Russie il perdent des généraux il les
remplace donc il y a des bois de son
armée au front qui recule et qui recule
sans cesse on en parle moins aujourd'hui
mais c'était ça la tendance depuis des
semaines déjà donc le choisit une fois
de plus aujourd'hui d'escalader je
voudrais même de tester encore une fois
les nerfs de l'Ukraine des Ukrainiens
des civils mais du gouvernement aussi et
la ténacité aussi des alliés à savoir
s'ils sont encore prêts à soutenir
l'Ukraine
qui est en communication avec son
cabinet bien sûr et qui est aussi en
attente des pays alliés d'aide
supplémentaires encore à quoi on peut
s'attendre contenu de ce qui vient de se
passer il a passé la journée une bonne
partie de la journée au téléphone entre
autres avec Justin Trudeau mais avec Joe
Biden aussi et de l'ONU a le temps de
l'Union européenne à Washington au
condamne ses attaques brutales et oui on
réitère le soutien à l'Ukraine mais quel
genre de soutien exactement the Lenski a
multiplié les appels à l'aide avec comme
prix priorité numéro un Brigitte cette
fois
la défense aérienne et il a donné
l'exemple vous savez des 80 quelques
missiles qui ont été lancés sur
l'Ukraine dans les dernières 24 heures
il y en a presque la moitié qui ont été
interceptés quand même grâce à des
systèmes de défense antimissiles donc
c'est ce qu'il supplie à l'Occident de
lui fournir et Washington aurait accepté
aujourd'hui en fin de journée de en
fournir davantage donc pour protéger
l'Ukraine je pense que c'est la priorité
aujourd'hui il y aura réunion d'urgence
du G7 demain pour discuter d'une réponse
coordonnée est-ce qu'on va aller plus
loin que les sanctions pour punir la
Russie de ce qui est qualifie
aujourd'hui d'acte de terrorisme et de
certaines de crimes de guerre donc on va
surveiller ça et on envoie aussi des
messages à lucaschenko président du
Belarus qui se dit prêt maintenant à se
battre côte à côte avec la Russie on
sait pas avec combien de soldats mais
ils préparent le terrain pour l'arrivée
de beaucoup de milliers de soldats
russes encore sur son territoire une
guerre qui est en cours depuis 7 mois
rappelons-le merci beaucoup Tamara